ليضعنا في صوره الوضع هناك في الميناء
وتواصل عمليات اجلاء اجانب وصول ايضا قطاع
بحريه اجنبيه التي ستقل لهم الى وجهاتهم
المختلفه
عمليه الاجلاء التي بدات فعليا قبل نحو
اربعه ايام هنا في مدينه بورسودان عبر
منفذيه امينه بورسودان ومطار فور سودان
الدولي لا تزال طبعا المستمره اليوم صباحا
كنا حضور لعمليه اجلاء بواسطه قطع عسكريه
سفينه بحريه حربيه هنديه اقامت باجلاء نحو
300 يعني من 300 شخص وهناك ايضا 300 شخص
ينتظرون في مدينه بورسودان انتظارا
لاكتمال الاجراءات يعني اجراءات سفرهم عبر
يعني
السفينه حربيه اخرى يتوقع ان تصل بعد قليل
هناك طائره ايضا الان تقوم باجراءات
الاجراءات الروتينيه في مطار قور سودان
الدولي ايضا ستقل مجموعه تقدر بنحو 300
شخص اخرين ايضا في هذه اللحظات هذه هذا
ميناء بورسودان هو واحد من المنافذ
الثلاثه ربما التي عن طريقه يتم اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب العرب منهم والاجانب من
السودان طبعا في ظل استمرار العمليات
العسكريه والمواجهات المحتدله ما بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم هذه
العمليه عمليه الاجلاء في يومها الرابع
اليوم
وامس كان هناك اجلاء لنحو لاكثر من الف من
الرعايه العرب والاجانب بينهم دبلوماسيون
ايضا ذهبوا تم اجلائهم الى مدينه جده على
متن باخره التجاريه هناك ايضا في مطار بور
سودان قبل قليل
الطائره عسكريه جزائريه تقل على متنها
اعداد من
الرعايه الجزائريين الذين كانوا في مناطق
متفرقه من الخرطوم اغلبهم جاء الى
بورسودان عن طريق
البري الذي يعني يصل ما بين الخرطوم
وبورسودان ويصل يطوله الى اكثر الى نحو
الف كيلو متر هذه العمليه بحسب اللجنه
المشتركه التي تم تشكيلها خصيصا لمواجهه
هذه الاجراءات عمليه الاجراءات المستمره
تتكون من قائد القائد العسكري القائد
القائد منطقه البحر الاحمر العسكريه
وعضويه جهات مختلفه ذات صله بعمليه
الاجلاء منها هيئه الموالي البحريه ومنها
اداره الجوازات وبعض الجهات الاخرى
هذه اللجنه التي تشرف على عمليه من عدد
كبير من الجنسيات لا تزال تقول انها يعني
تواجه تحديات كبيره فيما يتعلق باستمرار
هذه العمليه خاصه وانها يعني المنوط بها
من خلال الجيش السوداني توفير الحمايه
وتوفير السلامه بالنسبه للمسافرين منذ منذ
التحركهم في محاطتهم الاولى من الخرطوم
برا حتى وصولهم الى مدينه باريس سودان هذه
العمليه ايضا لاحظنا في مطار بورسودان
الدولي ان هناك اجراءات امنيه مشدده وفوق
العاده وعمليات تامين
بعسكريه حول مطار باور سودان الدولي مصادر
في الجيش السوداني قالت انها
بصدد بتاع التامين عمليه الاجلاء
تشمل طائرات التي تقل الذين يتم اجلائهم
فضلا عن مطار فور سودان الدولي هذه الايام
عليه حركه كبيره اغلب طائرات التي تحوط
على مطار فرسود تهبط هي طائرات عسكريه في
الاصل وان حتى البواخر او السفن التي تصل
الى ميناء بورسودان في اغلبها سفن عسكريه
او سفن حربيه
بعد قليل يعني علمنا بان وصول وصول عدد من
الموظفين الامم المتحده والمنظمات الدوليه
ايضا سيتم اجلائهم عن طريق البحر على متن
سفينه حربيه فرنسيه وصلت بالفعل في قبل
قليل ورست في ميناء بورسوداني انتظارا
لاكتمال عمليه العمليات الروتينيه
والاجراءات المتعلقه بعمليه سفرهم الى بلد
طبعا عمليه الاجلاء هنا في السودان بعد
الاحداث العنيفه في الخرطوم تكون على
ثلاثه
يعني ثلاث وسائل وسائل البريه عن طريق
الحدود السودانيه وبعض
مع الدول المشتركه سوى كانت اثيوبيا او
جنوب السودان وكذلك عبر مطار بورسودان
الدولي الذي هو يعد المطار الوحيد في
البلاد يعمل بشكله بشكل طبيعي ويستقبل
الطائرات
بانواعها لغرض عمل استكمال عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات منذ نحو اربعه ايام وتستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه وطبعا انهاء هذه العمليه على
الارجح انه يرتبط بانهاء انتهاء الازمه
الامنيه الكبيره والحرب ما بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني في مناطق من
الخرطوم اذن نحن نتحدث عن العمليه مستمره
نتحدث عن صعوبات في عمليه الاجلاء تتحدث
عنها البعثات الدبلوماسيه خاصه في بعد
تعرض بعض هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
لوسائل عنف سواء كان
قتل او النهض او اي وسيله من وسائل العنف
طبعا هذه مخاوف عبرت عنها عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ولكن الجيش السوداني يقول انه
عازم على انهاء هذه العمليه بشكل سليم
وانه يقوم بتامين هذه العمليه برمتها منذ
البدايه نعم وهذه الصعوبات والمخاوط طبعا
هي التي الان هي المسيطره على مواطن
السوداني في ظل وضع امنيا متوتر ومقلق جدا
وفي ضوء في ظل ايضا المخاوف على مستقبل
السودان اذا اصر الجانبان على المضي بعيدا
في هذا الصدام الع سكري واذا منهاره الهده
التي علق عليها السودانيين الكثير من
الامال لكي تستمر وان يتم البناء عليها
لربما
لعوده الى الهدوء وعوده الامن الى الحياه
في السودان